yeah 100 liberal for sure for sure and
then
i actually had a good friend in la i was
staying at her house
and we were watching cnn or something
before the last election
and she's like you know me and my whole
family vote for trump
and i i thought she's a crazy person and
i literally thought i
probably can't be friends with this
person anymore that means she's evil
she's a bad human
like i was like are you guys like racist
knowing her boyfriend is a black man i
thought it was weird
and eventually i realized oh no her
family just owns a bunch of businesses
and employs a lot of people
oh okay that makes sense for them why
they would support him and then
i started to see the unraveling of all
the things i've been taught
you go to enough parties in hollywood
you learn they're all douche bags
it's just it is what it is 98
you know the ones who live in texas most
of the time they're pretty dope
um yeah but i i started seeing that
every single thing that these people
pretend they are they are
actually the polar opposite
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today is a comedian
a social media superstar and a renegade
entertainer
nicole arbour finally welcome to the
review
oh my gosh i'm so excited this is
finally it's finally
it is finally finally is now all right
i'm really happy to have you here
because
i did not know you i didn't know who you
were now i know you a little bit
although we've only done it with this
stupid digital stuff we haven't met yet
yet but i didn't know you
until my book came out and then i was
doing all this press stuff and you were
one of the people that i i did like an
instagram live with
and i immediately turned to my producer
michael after and i was like
i need to know this girl we need to be
friends like she's
just great and fun and happy and you
care about politics but it doesn't
dictate your life
and blah blah blah blah blah so for the
people that know nothing
about you let's let's just introduce
nicole arbour who is nicole arbour what
is she all about
oh that's a good one thank you for the
compliments um
hi i'm nicole arbour i'm from canada but
then legal immigrant to america holler
holler
did stand up for tons of years after a
bad car accident
ended up doing stuff online because i
still could
and yeah i'm at over i'm over 80 viral
videos now
doing comedy straight to camera and i
freaking love it i also on the
my other secret life side work with
every major brand you can think of and
i've worked with every social media
platform you can think of
either on the dev team secretly helping
develop different
strategies for them or marketing
advertising and
it's the best and i have a lot of fun i
have a lot of fun
well you are having fun and you're happy
in the midst of all this
and you're kind of you're kind of one of
those people that i feel like you're not
really like a pure political beast but
when i open up twitter or i open up
instagram
i have a very short list of people that
i think are like kind of sane these days
you know and and you're on that list did
you always care about politics did you
just get kind of thrown into politics
i've always cared about it i i was in
politics when i was 18 years old
my very first official official job was
i was voted into this like junior prime
minister of canada role
in canada i was working for the federal
government making way more money than my
friends were
working at like mpp and mp's offices so
kind of like our senators
and people wanted me to go into politics
i actually had a scholarship for
political science
if i went through the liberal party of
canada and i went
nah i'm going to be a comedian it's
about the same the same and then
like seriously though so i really
started getting into it again a couple
years ago because
everyone started going nuts after trump
and
specifically i told this story a few
times two nights before
the last election i was on a platform uh
speaking at usc i was on a panel talking
about social media
um how it's in you know how it's working
through the election stuff like that
and people from hillary clinton's
campaign came up to me right before i
went on
these large men in suits and they told
me
that i'm going to say on stage that i'm
voting for hillary
and i was like well i'm a canadian first
of all so i'm not voting for anyone i
don't get to
they don't care about that social media
they don't care about that yeah like
i'm here to talk about as the first
people monetize on facebook and like how
it all works and
you know that kind of stuff and they're
like oh we really strongly suggest you
say this wow
and i recognize the one dude because he
worked on bill clinton's campaign years
ago
and i was just like yeah no i'm not
gonna and once i'm on stage doing the
talk with everyone
they put the words in my mouth so they
said on the mic you know nicole is just
backstage saying that she can't vote
this election but she would for hillary
and that was just like my freaking
switch in my head i was like
you [ __ ] okay
all right you're gonna put words in my
mouth and then i saw you know the media
over the last few years i saw all the
late night hosts i've grown up
loving and like looking up to just being
complete [ __ ] and spreading lies i
was like
i'm gonna start swinging at you guys you
won't see it coming and i'll take you
out in four episodes
so that's kind of where i'm at like i
just got pissed so i'm like okay i'll
start talking policy
i totally did not know that about you so
when they when they did this when they
introduced you at usc like that
did you say anything when you got on
stage or were you just too nervous or
you just wanted to get oh no i did
i did and i was like i definitely didn't
say that but hey
like i kept it sarcastic but the same
people
wanted me to do an interview with david
hogg who
i am not a fan of i i kind of think he's
made a career off the
you know dead students in his class i've
inquired to see how much he charges for
appearances and i think a kid getting
thirty thousand dollars
to talk about his friends maybe his
friends being shot at school
uh is pretty grotesque how much of that
are you giving to the families
right thirty thousand how much that's
going to the families how much of your
activism is actually active activating
anything
and not a fan of the kid i think he's a
dick so
i was still going to do the interview
and i do it's what i think
sad that that happened to you it's
tragic but kid's a dick
so i was gonna do the interview and
his like one of the other fathers that
were part of the the shooting
um they think they're giant celebrities
now and they stood up
all of their interviews that day they
just oh sorry we're busy we're going to
a dinner
so there's these camera crews and these
people and we're like
we came here to do an interview it took
hours to get to this location in la
and they went to a dinner instead so do
you care about your message or you're
just trying to be famous
and yeah that started it and they still
reach out to me that group of people to
be like hey nicole can you help us for
this election i'm like no
i think you're dicks and i see you lying
constantly so you've made an enemy and
i'm gonna beat you
yeah but the beauty is i mean as you're
saying this and you're smiling is you
really do do it through comedy like if
you want to tell people the truth and
not get punched in the face you got to
do it through comedy right that's uh
that's just kind of the way you got to
do it and that you really have mastered
that but
i'm curious did you were you kind of
right before then because i want to get
to when you kind of came out
for trump but were you always we both
had our kids yeah yeah
we had kind of similar events yeah yeah
yeah but
but like what were you before did you
did you consider yourself
liberal conservative blah blah blah so
liberal this is my liberal sweater by
the
way
at least liberal media okay this is like
freaking cnn reporters all over it
um yeah 100 liberal
for sure for sure and then i actually
had a good friend in la i was staying at
her house
and we were watching cnn or something
before the last election
and she's like you know me and my whole
family vote for trump
and i i thought she's a crazy person and
i literally thought i
probably can't be friends with this
person anymore that means she's evil
she's a bad human
like i was like are you guys like racist
knowing her boyfriend is a black man i
thought it was weird
and eventually i realized oh no her
family just owns a bunch of businesses
and employs a lot of people
oh okay that makes sense for them why
they would support him and then
i started to see the unraveling of all
the things i've been taught you go to
enough parties in hollywood you learn
they're all douche bags
it's just it is what it is
98 you know the ones who live in texas
most of the time they're pretty dope
um yeah but i i started seeing that
every single thing that these people
pretend they are
they are actually the polar opposite and
i went well
what's the opposite of [ __ ] i kind of
want to go that way
and i saw i caught you know even jimmy
kimmel i caught him multiple times
lying in stories yeah total lie and i
actually was responsible for outing him
twice he probably hates me
in the last year because i was like wait
a minute that doesn't seem right
i'd go to c-span and watch the full
uncut footage and then i'd do a quick
video on it and be like
jimmy kimmel did you just lie to your
entire audience
let's see and he did and then he issued
an apology a couple days later on
twitter
um he was lying about mike pence and one
of them
but the more i saw this the more i was
like [ __ ] tricked me
you tricked me doesn't it doesn't it
seem crazy to you that
you have to like fact check comedians
as a comedian like if you would have
said that to any any like eight-year-old
who wants to be a comedian and your job
will be to fact-check comedians through
comedy
you'd be like what the f are you talking
about
right you can swear with me it's okay i
saw you tell ben shapiro to swear i've
told him to swear multiple times too i
was
i was being hosti there but i would like
ben to say
yes i would yeah same just like just
once and then we could put it on a loop
and turn it to song exactly yeah
well it's ridiculous because i don't
want to fact check their jokes i don't
give a [ __ ] about their jokes be funny
satire do it even though facebook is
censoring jokes now which is kind of
weird
um but i never thought i'd have to fact
check the premise
of their joke you know like nicole
arbour dyed her hair black no i didn't
what do you what are you talking about i
wouldn't do that or that's a sign i'm
depressed
check on me um yeah i don't i don't like
it
and it got real weird and then it got so
weird
that i started researching myself like i
was like okay these crazy gun americans
and i flew down and i hung out with the
black rifle coffee guys
about two years ago this time and i was
like
okay yeah they're crazy but they're the
crazy that will rush in if there's an
issue and
save you we kind of need those crazies
you know
they're not going to use that gun on me
or some random they're going to defend
you if we need it
they're that crazy which is like a good
crazy yeah and then
i was scared of guns so i went to taran
tactical and i got trained on guns
and it was actually the military who
hooked me up with them and i was like
oh i see why people love doing this as a
hobby it's dope
like i've been like twitching while i
was in canada i couldn't shoot anything
sorry targets uh and then i started
you know going through all the things
that okay trump supporters are racist
i saw that they're not trump supporters
are
anti-american they're this they're that
they're against gay people i'm like
well i kind of feel like i might be a
trump supporter based on what they
believe
and i've helped organize world pride
multiple times
i was on a on a freaking float beside
jonathan van ness
a year ago for the pride parade that
guy's pretty gay he's
he's very gay he's like on the gay
spectrum he's like the gay
that makes carson presley look like
walter cronkite how is that for a
reference i
don't know who those people are i'm just
kidding
he does seem like he's about to explode
into glitter at any moment which i love
but i saw him even lie he said in a live
stream recently he's like all trump
supporters are homophobic
and they hate gay people and they're
against the lb lgbtq community
i was like [ __ ] i helped build your
float like
if i suddenly wanted to vote for trump
it doesn't change that i think you can
get married to whoever you want and be
happy and i love you
and i'm gonna dance with you in the
parade it just it was
it got so obvious and ridiculous and
just
purely absurd that i was like one side
seems crazy
and the other side seems like values
yeah but isn't it weird because
i mean one of the things that i love
about you is that you've been open about
your evolution
and you've just kind of gone where good
people are and that kind of thing which
is very
very much what i did as well like you
just kind of like
well wait a minute all the bad guys
actually seem like the good guys and the
people who are always telling you
they're the good guys they don't seem
that great or that tolerant
or that diverse or anything else but
i've never done this on the rubin report
before but i would like you to pick up
your phone
right now okay and i am going to ask you
to quote
yourself we're gonna we're gonna put up
we're gonna put up the image but i want
nicole arbour to do her best nicole
arbor impersonation because i believe it
was the day before the election am i
right
the day before the election i think it
was the day before
like two years maybe two days before you
put up a post on instagram that i
thought just
absolutely encapsulated so much
of why people that you would never think
traditionally would have voted for trump
or would have voted republican or
conservative
why they did it and so now nicole arbour
this is nicole arbour
as nicole arbour here we go
go team okay that was my impression of
me okay
i said and i meant this i said because
one day i'll be telling my grandkids to
stand up for what they believe when i
didn't
because i believe black people can vote
however they want and speaking down to
them
is racist because i am and will forever
be against censorship
of any kind it's dangerous it's wrong
and it's anti-american
because democrat-run cities are falling
to pieces like a zombie movie
because for four years i was called a
trump supporter as an insult
i wasn't at the time but it was used as
the worst thing you could call someone
and a quick jab by people who call
themselves liberals
the way they treat anyone different was
oh the way they treat anyone with
different views is
actually discrimination and isn't
liberal at all
it's gross no different from not liking
someone because of their race or
religion
because logic over feelings because i
grew up admiring the american dream
and he's the closest choice to restore
it for everyone
not just those who say the script and
fall in line ah here comes the good part
because most celebs are full of [ __ ]
because peace deals and new partnerships
because he stood in the face of lie
after lie media hit peace after media
hit peace as a flawed leader is
refreshing
real because he didn't start a single
war because biden sniffs little girls
and is clearly unfit
mentally to lead a boy scout troop let
alone a country because trump will lead
north america not just america to the
best four years we've seen
and because my friends and family and
you
can disagree and i'll still be cool with
you because this side allows
conversation
that's kind of how giant peace deals
were signed i'm nicole arbour i'm a
libertarian and i endorse donald j
trump for president yay
nicole you do a fine nicole rooting
myself was hard i started sweating
yeah but that right there and the way
you did it
like just so human and real and like not
like i'm this
crazy extremist and all that stuff i
just
i really just thought it was perfect and
yes when you give it to the celebrities
who are just so
full of [ __ ] i mean i live in this town
i live in la i know these people they're
not good people
they're just there's not they're going
to tell you
i have one story i don't know if i
should tell you tell me if i should tell
it you must there's a female celebrity
that a lot of people know oh here we go
all right here we go all right there was
a female comedian celebrity
i will say the name at the end because
it's more fun as a result okay good
that a couple two years ago when there
was the giant fires in malibu
um i saw her post on her social media
that there was a bunch of animals
trapped at the malibu wine safari
like trapped in the fires couldn't get
out yeah
so i was part of a search and rescue
team just because i'm a canadian and
this is what we naturally do
um so i went and i told the search and
rescue team hey i just got
this tip about this look at this story
truckloads of us went up into the
mountains
during the fires with these giant animal
crates we were like oh we have to rescue
this giraffe we have to get all these
animals
so we have to get all these big animal
containers that they usually use for
zoos or to transfer animals
there was i think there was like 10 or
something of us going up there
it took an hour to get in through the
fires
we get there ready to rescue these
animals
and they were fine they were never at
any point in danger
it was a lie it was totally social
justice warrioring
all over the interwebs and the zookeeper
was in tears this tiny little mexican
man this is his whole life
he's in he came out running in his socks
crying and he's like please stop taking
photos and stuff with my animals and
pretending that they're being abused
this girl came here earlier said she was
gonna try and help raise money for us to
rebuild because the buildings were
burned down but not the animals
and she took all these selfies and stuff
and he let her and then she released
them
to the press as if something bad
happened to these animals and they were
abused
i came back i felt so bad for these
people i came back the next day with the
press
walked around with the fire chief who
said that
the place was so safe he would have put
his men where they had their animals
during the fire
um the spca came with us all the press
came with us and walked around the
entire property to show
what she had said is a lie because she
was troll business
turns out she had a personal vendetta
against the business it's whitney
cummings
so this does not does not surprise me
yeah well i listened to her and i put
the lives of like 10
it was like 10 to 12 people our lives
were literally in danger we knew that it
was a scary situation
and i saw her post and i believed her
and i went into the [ __ ] fires
to save all these creatures freaking
noah's ark over here
and they were fine and then she wouldn't
tell the
press that she had exaggerated she's
like well there was blood in his nose
i'm like yeah
the draft got a nosebleed because there
was a fire around him it's dry
and then she called and apologized to me
at one point and said you know
i i shouldn't have responded like that
to you
whatever and i'm like okay we can be
cool again me being canadian
then i meet her in person and she was a
total douche bag to me
as if it was my fault for revealing that
the thing she made up wasn't real
and i'm just like jeez these social
justice warriors are
[ __ ] you almost killed people
because you have a personal vendetta
against the wine safari like whatever it
was
yeah it started for me there i'm telling
you
can we do a little bit of the the what
happened to comedians kind of thing we
we talked about kimmel a little bit
that's just like
that's like late night tv a certain set
a certain level of them
but like what the hell has happened to
comedians there are like
basically no funny comics anymore i want
to do some stand-up stuff with you we
were talking about it before this
you know and then the whole stupid
lockdown thing but like watching some of
these people that used to be
funny sarah silverman cummings
uh it happens to uh amy schumer like it
happens to be a lot of females but it
but it's the men too i mean they've all
look pat and oswald
all of these people that have just gone
totally bananas
like did you see it coming did you see
it coming
i didn't see it coming i didn't and it
like for a little like
i don't know if you could see who's over
my shoulder this is like my wall of
heroes
oh yeah uh god if he was alive right now
they'd be saying he's an old white rich
man i mean that's what they'd be calling
him while he'd be fighting the power
accurate that's fine um i
kind of love everything that's happened
to stand up and to comedy
and this whole like everything is wrong
stand up for blah blah blah
shut up amy schumer showing up to the
woman's march with your supermodel
friend to pose in her belly top saying
don't objectify women while she twerks
for money in a thong
shut the [ __ ] up all of you shut the
[ __ ] up
get out of the way but because they're
so crazy it made a new breed of comics
and i'm so happy i swear like the day
after the election
i saw all of the comedians just kind of
like snap
all the really good ones i'm talking
like andrew schultz scott he's
he's so good um i'm talking like who
else like chris de stefano do you know
him i don't i don't oh
you need to you're going to love him
i saw them kind of like snap to i saw
all these comedians just like this
little spark wet in their eyes like
we give up we've been we're okay we're
going
and everyone's just been like going and
it's been really fun to watch and i
think it
cracked people to where comedy is just
gonna go
boom again so you think we'll have a
boom in comedy because it was so
bad and so you know social justice
virtue signaling lefty nonsense
that you think after now we're gonna
have like a second explosion like an 80s
explosion or something
oh yeah i'm thinking even someone like a
john crist i don't know if you know him
oh people really knew him for more like
kind of christian comedy and he kind of
stays in that like hilarious and witty
safe space
of the christian comedy his last like
eight videos have just been
lethal and he's just like going after
the leftists and i'm like okay
like everyone is just starting to hammer
on it because it's so ridiculous
and i've decided i have like thrown out
all my other plans for 2021.
i'm doing a late night show good i have
multiple offers
thank you do it i'm excited i have to
come on yeah i'm just gonna go right
at them i'm gonna take them out i have
offers from multiple networks right now
and uh
we'll see where i land but i'm out for
blood i'm gonna take them out
that's it i'm beyond thrilled to hear
that and i will gladly do the show and
that that would be awesome and i would
love to tour with you when we could get
this
when this lunacy ends at some point um
right before we started you told me uh
you told me something's going down with
the washington post was it
my god okay so this is fun because i do
have my secret tech life i get calls a
lot from
magazines or whoever just about new tech
that's out and parlor i'm sure we're
both familiar
um straight up it's a dope app when i
did a dive into it i was
disgustingly impressed i know the
features that they have rolling out in
january
i'm not allowed to say yet but they're
great anything i could have wanted they
have coming
user friendly you can monetize it
already once you hit 50 000 followers
it's dope if i were the platforms i'd be
a little bit nervous
and i talked to the washington post
about it i'm looking at her name
what's her name oh rachel lerman i did
an interview with her
about tech and that platform
specifically
and her only follow-up questions for me
were
where do you live like it was between
she wanted to know what cities i live in
and wanted me to confirm i'm a trump
supporter
what do those have to do with me
speaking to her about text
yeah and about the applications and how
brands can use it to sell their products
nothing it's nothing so does anything
surprise you at this point when it comes
to the media you're all over the media
too i mean just like is there
anything that they could do at this
point that you would consider
shocking or a new low it's like there's
there's just no there there there's no
there's no
no there's no bottom to this bottomless
pit
they could they could just drop the act
and get in a circle and just jerk each
other off
like just like just drop the facade we
all know what you guys do
um i remember like couple days back uh
i think it was julian and he was just
laying into them in a press conference
and
that was funny [ __ ] you saw it i think
it's mock them back to their faces
do it you saw that moment when at the
press conference giuliani he says
where are you from the girl goes cnn and
then giuliani powell and jenna ellis all
the trump's lawyers they just start
laughing because cnn has become a punch
line
it is it's a punch line and it reminds
me of like when there was those first
round of riots
and they went after the cnn building and
i was just like yeah
look i hope i hope nobody's inside but
oh it's fun like in all of the chaos
there always comes some new spreads of
hope and i
really think comedy is going to swing
the other way now and i'm excited to
go punch it at all of them yeah how have
you managed
like what do you think it is about you
that manages to keep you
happy and sane throughout this because
i've seen so many of
friends colleagues family members blah
blah blah that have just
even the ones that kind of get it that
are basically same but just they're just
crushed by all of this all the time and
you're not that's silly
i'm not i'm not uh i don't like violence
when those things erupt i get a little
affected by that um
because i know that the other side has a
lot of guns
and the people that you keep poking at
they're a big [ __ ] bear
and you poke one too many times they're
gonna bite you and it's not gonna be
cute so that's the only thing that
scares me
but outside of that i just i've been
through real pain
i like i spent most of my 20s disabled
on disability
in bed most of the time what was that
what was that yeah
car accident and see i even smile when i
say it now
um a lot of people know this about me a
lot of people don't but
2008 i had a bad car accident after a
show
and most of my 20s were lost
and it was between treatments chronic
pain
physical disabilities i crushed my own
teeth in my mouth from
tmj so bad from nerve pain it was it was
horrific
it like i wouldn't wish it on anyone
i don't think it could get much worse
than it was
and i've come back from it when i wasn't
supposed
to so when stupid [ __ ] happens or people
who are offended by
nonsense or pretend that animals are
dying in a fire like
have you not suffered for real like it
just doesn't affect me the same way i'm
like
in the pandemic and all this stuff with
politics i'm like there's people losing
their businesses that's the most
important let's help them
yeah you're complaining about what today
okay
you need to shut the [ __ ] up there needs
to be like a mute button i think on all
of social media
that if people are talking about
nonsense we just mute them
for everybody yeah well there is a beaut
button
yeah but like for the whole world like
no you get muted today like i saw people
going at like
dan crenshaw a couple days ago too and
i'm just like
just stop just just let's just not like
dan crenshaw
the most solid dude freaking stoic beast
of a man
maybe he's not right all the time but i
think it always comes from a good place
you're gonna try and cancel him and go
at him on twitter just
you're you're all muted you're muted for
the day everybody who did that
like there should be a twenty period of
okay
do you see any way censorship like
i know you don't want them jailed and
sent to the gulag and booted you just
want them
you just don't want to have to listen to
them i can appreciate that yeah
i try not to use words i can't spell so
gulag is one of them
g-u-l-a-g you can do that come on okay
i'm writing it down write that down
write that down
okay i'm doing it um okay so i want to
mention one other thing about the
election and now i'm going to read as
nicole arbour how does that sound
i can't wait for your impression i hope
it's not going to go well we're going to
put the image up so this is a tweet that
you sent out on november 15th
the election was november 3rd so 12 days
after the election
you sent out this tweet which i shared
and it really caught fire and i think
and i've seen other people steal it by
the way since then where they've just
copied and pasted
and not credited you but here we go
here we go i'm not i'm gonna do this is
dave rubin
as dave rubin reading nicole arbour
number one election is held number two
citizens votes are counted number three
participants may contest procedures
you are here and that's in caps number
four
results are certified number five
elector vote
votes are cast number six elector votes
are counted
number seven winner is declared
some think you are here when i saw this
tweet i was like
ah it's the perfect illustration of
everyone being confused about everything
because even people that i know that are
that are
bright political people are pretending
that we're at number seven that just
because the ap
and cnn said something but that means
we're there
but we ain't there we ain't there
it's kind isn't it kind of weird that we
have to exp like i am
not from america why do i know
this you know it's not that like in
canada we learned both american and
canadian political procedures
and i knew that i know that those are
the steps and a fan actually sent me the
steps and i was like yeah okay i'm going
to tweet it like this
but why don't americans know that it's
kind of weird and it's kind of silly
that we're flipping out like you got to
go to second base before you go home
what are you guys doing right like
baseball 101. we got to do this in a
certain order i think the reason for
that actually is because a lot of people
want to be at seven so badly whether
we're supposed to be there or not that
they're just saying okay
we're we're at three yeah those are the
guys who roll off you and go oh did you
have fun too
you came right yeah it's like okay
that's how i feel about them
who do you trust i just pictured harry
trump in a dress
um who do i trust yeah like
how do you well how do you make some
sense of all this stuff like i'm always
looking around when i find voices that
seem kind of sane and interesting and
like somewhat
trustworthy how do you find people
because people always come up
people literally come up to me at the
supermarket they'll be like dave you're
the only one i trust
and i'm always like well [ __ ] we got a
big problem here
people say that to me too they're like
you're the only one that tells the truth
and i really pride myself on that i'll
keep telling the truth and throwing in
my silliness and
the fun part is that i love being wrong
because then i get to learn
the right thing so i don't even care if
i'm wrong but i trust
i'd say i trust you i trust ben shapiro
minus 10 because i'll just make up for
the silly
because it's in there um i trust
rogan's show joe rogan's show yeah um
and it's not even that i trust their
opinions i just trust that they like to
learn
so his guests and him they'll work their
way through [ __ ] i like that
i trust erica who is the ceo of bar
stool
and pretty much the whole barstool
sports crew i think they tell it like it
is too
yeah kind of kind of crazy that bar
stool has to be so involved in politics
though right
it's really funny it's really really
funny and
this is why i'm saying the pendulum's
coming back when this
the people who are supposed to be
serious have gone
crazy then the crazies are going to have
to take over
and we're running the asylum and we have
more experience this is the thing
they don't they don't get it they're out
when we go crazy we're going to be way
better than them
but are you afraid that if trump
does not pull off this stuff with the
lawsuits and stuff and
biden becomes president that at that
point why wouldn't
big tech just get rid of all of us you
know they're calling us all nazis anyway
the entire political establishment will
say
you're a bunch of nazi trump supporters
i don't like to say it publicly
obviously okay okay
i was i was under the impression nicole
the son this on youtube
oh okay all right yeah i'm so sorry like
i thought you were like
a gay nazi yeah my bad
but but really like are you afraid of
that that like why wouldn't you know
you've built
your life and career and all that
goodness on the to on the pipes of
youtube and facebook and twitter and
instagram and all that
like are you worried that you know
january 20 rolls around biden's
president and within the next couple
weeks like why would big tech not just
boot everybody who's deplorable and a
bad guy and a nazi and the rest of it
uh because money they like money
everything they do is
this is where my tech nerdside comes in
everything they do
is to keep people on that platform
longer and to keep them looking at more
ads and watching more videos and earning
them more ad revenue
they have no reason to get rid of 70
something million people like this
like they're not going to infinity wars
us because they like our money
you know they like our eyeballs they
wanna do it so i don't think it's gonna
happen
it's not in their best interests and
this is what i
hope tv hop tv network tv networks learn
too many thoughts at once red bull
um sweet jesus slow down woman they're
i'm trying i'm trying
they're just playing to one side and
there's 70 other million people to
entertain
you dumb asses guess what all those
people do they buy toilet paper
they buy makeup they buy hair products
you clearly do wow
um it's it's wow it's amazing
i mean the hair game if we toured
together would be seriously like
strong let's just have our hair on
t-shirts like just the outlines of our
hair
i like it that'd be fun nicole and dave
nicole and dave
that's my brother's name too so it's fun
um yeah
i just think it would be really stupid
of them economically to not start
playing to the other half of america and
north america
people forget that canadians very much
follow american politics and chime in on
it because we're attached
we're your hat and uh yeah what's going
on i think i don't think
what's going on with your guy up there
trudeau you must love that guy huh
that robot malfunctioned a while ago we
gotta like
hearing him in between doing blackface
telling us how to be good people is just
it's too much for me
he talks in a fake robot voice now
it's it's just too much how did he how
did he win a re-election like because
most western countries
and now it's a little up in the air with
the us but in the last like five years
most western countries
they they went to the right but you guys
you went the other way and now he's
talking great reset
the humanoid that he is wait reset yeah
okay
bring it um which is probably why i get
at least a hundred people asking me
every day to run for prime minister
and they're not kidding and i've had
financial backers
ask me if i would do it they want me to
run for governor of california now
you see what you do how stupid is this
i mean arnold kind of broke the mold for
us like years ago so that's pretty good
but i don't want to be prime minister
the salary cap is 180 000 canadian
that's frankly like
nah you know for all that pressure
that's like
23 american not into it um
but yeah yeah that takes me down another
tangent yeah but
what do you think i would get people
like that trudeau like like what
what is happening in canada
he's gonna be out soon the thing is we
just didn't care enough
canadians follow american politics
more than we follow canadian politics it
just is what it is
yours is more entertaining it's more fun
the characters are better it's a good
reality show
ours is kind of like where and we're too
polite there's not a lot of fighting
in our house of commons and we just kind
of let things skirt by
until suddenly this douchebag is talking
about the great reset in his robot voice
um then it's getting a little weird and
he's fighting with
the premiere of ontario about giving
the cash advances to small businesses
that they promised over a month ago
then i'm like okay who's who are we
tagging in here because now someone has
to go take this guy out like
election-wise not like take him out yeah
i got it you're not calling for the
assassination of justin
i am not calling for the assassination
of justin trudeau facebook did you hear
that
okay because you know i've gotten in
trouble jokes before with facebook
listen the media matters people
they watch this show with a keen eye
waiting for me to pause the wrong way or
for one of my guests
to accidentally say something because
skype freaked out for a moment so we
have to be very careful you do not
want justice is that true yeah these
people are pathetic
ridiculous fools oh
tell me what you really think at least
they didn't send you to your fiery death
to rescue horses
that were fine you see there you go
wait do you guys think it's a little
weird you guys you canadians we don't
really understand you people up north
do you guys i think it's weird the way
that that we that it seems like our
issues have been imported into canadian
shores because
every gig that i did in canada and when
i was with jordan and when i've done
solo gigs
people are crazed and starving for the
types of things that i talk about and i
did an event with um
maxine bernier who was the people's
party of canada you know basically the
libertarian candidate for prime minister
and we did an event and anti-fo was
there and they were throwing things
and attacking us and screaming nazi that
video you probably saw that video of the
woman with the walker
trying to cross the street that was for
me to come to canada to talk about free
speech like
insane but but and then you have all
these people and they're screaming black
lives matter and all this stuff and it's
like
well is there a problem with police
shootings in canada and does it have
anything to do with race and then you
ask them and they're like no
no that's like well what are you
screaming about
no we just we want to play yeah we want
to play tv that's what it is
that's what it is literally i just when
canadians start going off about issues i
laugh most of the time because i would
say our number one
issue if we have issues outside of
pandemic and stuff like that
is environmental it's where we gonna lay
pipeline uh for natural oil
what you know indigenous lands can we go
through what's not cool let's
let's make peace with the indigenous
indigenous people
those are the real issues canadians have
and i'd say number one is environmental
other than that we're kind of chill and
i think that makes some people antsy so
they make up problems just like everyone
else
in the world they have nothing to
complain about so they make it up
i just remembered something i don't
think i told you did i ever
did i ever tell you that i messaged you
while you were in hamilton ontario
oh during that for that that was for
that gig right
yeah i didn't know you yet but i saw
that that was happening
and i reached out to i think on
instagram and i offered you
uh another venue with a ton of security
yeah
nicole you are a good woman
this is going to sound very douchey i
don't run my instagram
that's okay it does but it's okay
no i mean i got a guy that runs it and
sometimes messages sometimes things slip
through well i appreciate
i mean that thing really was i was like
i cannot believe
this is happening in canada i got people
screaming that i'm a nazi
the three speakers on stage you had a
christian a jew and a muslim on stage or
they're screaming that it's a white
supremacist event
you guys failed at white supremacy so
hard yeah
so hard so hard hitler would be hitler
would be very
very disappointed so i was about to ask
you what's next for you but i think we
know what's next which is you got some
sort of late night situation coming
that's awesome
i do and it's gonna be fun and i know i
sound a little like
evil villain about it but that's how i
feel i feel like okay
you guys want to play you pushed good
people this far
the people's champions are rising up or
we're gonna swing and
i can't just be like oh it's just me i'm
gonna take on everybody there's a
freaking
x-men crew rising up right now and man
i feel bad for snl i feel bad for these
people that are stuck in the little
boxes
can't say what they want can't be real
comics because yeah
the good ones are coming nicole arbour
you're the best you're you're top ten
right now your top ten
people that exist on the internet i'm
putting you out there on that you're a
top tener
oh thanks you are also in the top ten
and your hair is like in the top one you
win for hair
you're the hair god for sure you know
how much i'm paying for hairspray these
days
you get this kind of lift what kind do
you use can you tell me
can i tell you off camera because it's a
very special brand and i'm afraid if i
tell everybody that everyone will have
it and then every and then i won't be
able to get it can i just
yeah 100 i do have i do have some limits
around okay yeah
nicole i can't wait i can't believe we
haven't met in real life and actually
like
had a beer or something so i can't wait
to actually do that
and i'm pre-congratulating you on your
nighttime
show and i'll see you on the
instagram woohoo bye thanks for having
me go team bye
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell